[Music]
and welcome back everybody to another
awesome episode of the careful boys well
we are extremely carefully here and
saying the most careful things we've got
tesh here today
tesh
um just off camera actually though we
were talking a little bit about some
sims stories and we heard a little bit
of of a bart sim story that was just
bart simpson
wait what do you thought sims story no
sense oh i wish it
[Laughter]
so we have a mutual friend we were
talking about um
me too man so we went
[Laughter]
we went to the same high school together
um but we didn't know each other back
then because when i left he came in
right but we were reminiscent about
the same thing yeah people that we might
and there's a mutual girl that we know
that bart had a crush on
well it's crazy so it's a small world
it's a small world um her name is
anthony lee and you guys are all eskimo
brothers for it
[Music]
do you have that many dicks in your
butthole
we never hooked up what
you hooked up with everyone here except
for me um don't you want some spice in
your life um that was his past life
i'm i'm trying not to feel gay right now
um
that's a part so this is pretty crazy
because it's like it's just crazy how
small of a world is like we just found
out we were connected another way
through sean and alec
you know it's just like like because
we're all parts of soul cal but then we
know mutual people it's a small world
it's a small world so um
i met this chick uh
i remember going to elac and you know
like all the like depending on what
you're making easterly community college
depending on your majors you're kind of
revolving around the same buildings
and then so i was a science major and i
saw this chick walking around like a
couple of times i'm like oh man she's
cute
and then i went to bali's during in
rosemead
and uh women's dreams like total fitness
oh they go to bali
yeah
it was for a little bit and uh probably
later
they they definitely marketed towards
women yeah she was on the treadmill
running
and i was you know do you remember have
you guys ever been there i know joe has
valley's total fitness and rose mead
yeah
it's by the target man so there's a uh
there's a track that goes around the
whole gym
so i was
walking around the track i saw her and i
was like oh [ __ ] that's that girl from
school i need to find a way to talk to
her so i just keep walking around on the
track i've got to figure out something
to say figure out something to say this
was back in the day when you actually
had to talk to women yeah
this is 2004 like 2004. you can't just
airdrop them dick pics
2004 this is like iphone 2
not even iphone one what did the iphone
maybe the sidekick no not even no kids
no kids next toe yeah so i don't even
know what i had i i remember walking and
then i was like all right you know what
i'm just gonna say some [ __ ] [ __ ]
or whatever
and then i'll just let it come out and
then i'll roll up the punches so
i walk up to her i see her walking with
her headphones in and i'm like oh do you
come here a lot
classic come here often
she was like she's like what i'm like oh
you got like headphones in here you
can't hear me
she's okay oh you come here and then she
goes um she takes it out and then she
goes uh
she goes what'd you say and i'm like oh
do you come here a lot she goes
yeah i come here i'm like oh cool yeah i
come here too so i just kept walking ah
come on bart
nothing happened
dude
19. i'm scared you know and i'm like all
right okay whatever
i probably blew it and then um
the what is it called the next time i
saw her at school
like you come here a lot
i said some [ __ ] like that but i
think it was all like hey are you here
i think it was more like
oh it's you from bali's no way you come
here too you come to school
she never seen you at school no she's
never seen me at school
and no no he does the only thing you
said you come here a lot and she goes ha
and then you walked away i was scared
man i was [ __ ] scared that's scary
and then yeah it is so i saw her at
school probably blew it again
and i was like oh [ __ ] this is this is
horrible and then um
one time i saw her walking out and i was
able to like walk with her to to her
next class and actually have a
conversation where she laughed i'm like
cool this is do you remember what you
said to make her don't remember um but i
do remember appropriate telling joe i'm
like there's this girl that
i like
she's cute and i think i showed joe
her myspace or something tired hey
when you said this is this girl i liked
it did you like know things about her or
was it just because you were attracted
to her i liked the way she looked nice
but by this time by back then he fell in
love before he even met the person
exactly he just sees them and he's all
like oh that girl we're going to be
together forever i told y'all that's my
wife i told joe i met my wife
and then joe's like what the [ __ ] i
[ __ ] know who she is i'm like oh [ __ ]
hook it up then and then um
i don't remember what
like
uh but we ended up
trading like numbers
and like pokemon cards too you traded
yeah and we started hanging out
and this is the part where it gets crazy
because
she had a boyfriend at the time oh
your side piece so you're the side piece
and this is where i think it ties into
us because we're talking about this yeah
so she has a boyfriend at the time and
i'm like oh [ __ ] then i asked my dad and
then i was like hey dad so there's this
i don't even talk about that's the worst
can you distract your boyfriend
do you ask your dad for advice on girls
yes dad if he comes here a lot
so i only asked my dad on stuff for
stuff that i like
where i have no other options will you
have it you want a shitty answer his dad
always gives the worst advice yeah so i
was like
hey dad there's this girl
that i like her personality based off
her face
[Laughter]
and i was like um
but she has a boyfriend what do you
think i should do and he was like
your like boyfriend girlfriend is just a
tryout period if they're serious they
would have gotten married i like it dude
that's classic my dad would have said
something very similar yeah old school
so i was like
all right that's what my dad said so we
started hanging out and um it got pretty
serious where like we would go on dates
and stuff and we would um like she would
be the last person that
i mean i would be the last one she
talked to at night
more and more and more and then if she
would like let's say she knows i'm
starting from the finals she would come
and bring me food to my house oh
and or like if we're gonna go or if
we're gonna go to the gym like she would
come to my house pick me up and it's out
of the way
so it got really really really serious
and it was crazy because we're behaving
like boyfriend and girlfriend in terms
of like
um emotional intimacy and like how much
we hung out that i was like wait do you
have a boyfriend how come like
how come i'm the duder with all the time
and i'm like okay i have to like even he
was confused by it
dude but not even for sex it was like
emotions doesn't that sound like a
friend zone thing yeah yeah yeah yeah so
which is crazy right so i was like okay
i gotta let her know what if she just
thought that he was gay the entire time
you're a gay best friend we gotta call
her up right now
but here's the thing it's like there's
this um
well anyways so i i sat i
was like we got we gotta i felt like
there's too much in the air that's not
cleared up
so
um i met met up with her i told her like
how i felt about her and like that i
liked her and all that stuff
and
like she was like i think she was like
um
what's the word she was happy
but then also
regretful
and then also kind of ashamed yeah cause
you made it too real yeah you pop you
made it too real dude don't make it too
real man
we figured that the best the best bet
would be to not talk at all anymore
right and so we stopped talking for like
maybe a month that's very bart style and
then i don't know what happened we
started hanging out again and this time
it gets crazier because
um
like when we would hug at night to part
ways she would go down it would be long
hugs and i could have sworn a few times
she would like kiss me on the neck
without kissing me on the neck
you know what i mean she like spit she
just spit on your neck
take that you [ __ ] gay guy
but what's crazy is like if you know how
christian she is like
my way of trying to understand her
is like i think she's trapped in this
crazy christian mindset and she really
actually likes me but she doesn't want
to deal with the reality of her
boyfriend and
like really having to like set things
straight she kind of just like likes the
things as is and crossing the line so
far where she did something wrong
exactly
did she ever have a conversation with
you about him or about
you two and like in relationship to that
or like
making a difference no never she never
took it to that that far and then
so there's a big fiasco that happened
but two weeks leading up to that we
started holding hands and stuff too oh
[ __ ] dude because that's when it got
past the friend zone yeah you broke it
because i was like you hang out with her
too much you need to start touching her
you need to [ __ ] do something yeah i
can only imagine his advice during this
during this process what was your hair
like back then i was bald but completely
yeah
so you were you were like you were
better you were like oh i'm gonna smash
this table and it was [ __ ] dick right
here so yeah it was getting it was
getting you choose that out of
everything it was [ __ ] dick right
here yeah so it's getting pretty crazy
so since we since we hung out so um
like so late into the night the the the
night that sparked everything off and
blew everything out of proportion and
like the ultimate moment that came out
was i drop her off at her pet
and then as i drive away um
i guess like her boyfriend at the time
calls their house phone because everyone
still had house phones at the time
and i think
her sister
was like
oh i don't know he just got dropped off
by a guy or something like that
and then that's where it was that's when
it started because i got home
take out the sisters kneecaps
crazy phone calls from her and she's
like crying and stuff and i'm like
what's going on she's like oh my
boyfriend found out my boyfriend found
out i found out about what we didn't do
[ __ ] and then she was like
you know you gotta talk to him whatever
and then
told you to um to him or not told me to
talk to him but like i don't know she's
frantic right i don't know spitting on
my neck
your girl drooling on my neck and now
you
we've been holding hands and [ __ ]
platonically and then exactly who you
think gave me this and then uh yeah
she's like oh and i guess because like
i'm in such simp mode that i cared about
her so much and then since she was
getting heat from
her boyfriend i was like i'll i'll talk
to him you're the mistress bro
you're like let me go you got nothing to
lose so i talked to you guys
this fool starts crying on the phone and
[ __ ]
yeah this dude starts crying on the
phone
and he was like he's like oh man i can't
believe he's been hanging out with you
did you spit on your neck too
[Music]
uh she broke my heart whatever and i
started lecturing him
qualities that i liked this ultimate set
moment all the qualities because she was
like man i'm gonna [ __ ] dump this
stupid ass [ __ ] and saying all these
things i think she's not a [ __ ] dude
oh yeah she's a [ __ ] for sure leave her
to me
[Laughter]
like can you believe this this girl do
both of us yeah like you didn't do that
my scent pass was uh she's not a [ __ ]
man she's that's this good quality and
if you you liked her man yeah you're
like
apologizing the right amount of time
should probably forgive you too and and
like just the opposite of what's in my
face that's kind of good advice
something like a dumbass
and uh that whole if you love someone
you let them go right yeah the whole
thing popped off oh my god you repaired
them and
i repaired them
and then i thought it was going to be
one of those things where it dies down
later on i could talk to her their love
got intense or maybe they broke up she
fell in love or some [ __ ] like that
right i messed her a couple times on
myspace nothing happens and then
um facebook
one last time i sent her a couple posts
one last time was
her best friend i forgot her name but
she messaged me
and then she told me leave her the [ __ ]
alone it gives me this whole big ass
thing like like [ __ ] going in and i'm
like oh [ __ ]
okay i could take that
and then uh for like maybe a week or two
i was like so [ __ ] depressed like
even my dad came and checked up on me
he's like dude are you okay or yo your
asian dad checked to see if you were
depressed oh dude you must have been
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah obliterated
that's not even in the vocabulary yeah
like he hasn't shouted for like a week
yeah you're not gonna kill like do me
stupid kill yourself right now
four i think like maybe a few years
later
two years later did you even go to a
church and ask god to give her back to
you and you weren't even christian
you told me that [ __ ] wow
best friend's secrets coming out no he
said because he's like man he goes i
ain't even christian but i was so after
that whole fiasco he's all like i
[ __ ] pulled up i saw a church i
[ __ ] the church was open and i just
started praying in that [ __ ] i was like
yeah and i was like i was like you don't
even [ __ ] breathe i don't remember i
don't know what heart has a heart maybe
i don't i don't even remember that but
uh bart's kind of a sweetheart but we're
like bart that's hard i don't remember
that yeah
he's like dude come on i got an image to
keep i saw her on atlantic i remember
once i made fun of him we're
driving i saw him atlantic right after
that whole thing
i saw her and then i smiled at her and
she looks at me she just goes like this
and just drives off oh my oh [ __ ] that's
like literally oh my gosh hey she was
the first one why do you think she was
so upset at you you think because she
gave you an opportunity to seize the day
and you just were like because
he fixed something that she was hoping
to get out of maybe and that was like
the crescendo and the crescendo's always
really cuz she didn't want to be the bad
guy yeah it seems like she wanted you to
do the dirty work yeah and then he did
he did he did god's work
you did
yeah that guy apologized and she was
like [ __ ] this is even worse and now
they're married and have 16 kids that
she regrets she probably
blamed you for where is she now her
infidelity i don't know this i mean so
long ago uh we'll find out we know her
yeah are you looking for her right now
is that no
shut the [ __ ] up that's not her
that is not her
he pulled out someone with the same name
and she looks like a really big person
chopping at walmart
doesn't matter that's not her dude maybe
she doesn't work at bali's anymore
she works at walmart you know is that
the right ethnicity
no she's sure she's like arabic
that's her yeah yeah
no it's not here
hey that's the right name though right
yeah cowboy hat and all yo hey was my
description accurate was my was my
description right send her a message be
like hey do you come here a lot
and what's crazy is once i got to ucla
because she was gonna go there too once
i got to ucla um my roommate
who were like you know like you just
have like deep talks and stories with
your roommate she was like
wait that's her name she's in my class
and i was like
what the [ __ ] by the way she follows you
everywhere like that you know what's
weird crazy dude i would have never she
was the one that violated all the rules
and then she blamed you
yeah she was the one stepping out of her
relationship and her boyfriend she
didn't even have the courage to let her
boyfriend know that she's still with the
yeah she's still with that guy i have no
idea sister rather than but then you
thought that guy that was with it might
be the same guy that you were telling me
because he was just like before he was
like man she was with this one guy that
he shouldn't even been with her she
didn't even like him do you think she'll
see this i don't think so should we send
it to her i know
you guys are pretty famous
you guys are pretty famous should we
send you something
i will say i will say two times no
three times
people have pulled me aside to take a
photo with me and they're like
we saw you on jk news that was her
running away right now
she was right about to come say what's
up geo might have even met her before
what because she was being your best
friend uh at the time
probably jewish
was your best friend she was dating my
best friend at the time and uh chio is
dating your best bart likes dating women
are you still friends with this guy who
no no no
no bart likes but he watches
relationships oh he does he watches yeah
because i told the story about our
matching tattoo and then he sent the
video because i was like i don't know if
he covered it up or not and he sent that
video to our mutual friend that he stole
he goes i still have oh that's cool you
got a matching tattoo with your ex best
friend yes before they were ex-best
friends yeah of course yeah yeah of
course
or that's absolutely or after that's
right what does it say well now it says
that's right it's wrong too
i'm afraid i'm afraid of everybody
it says i'm afraid of everybody this is
2003 google translate
google translate
google translate why'd you ask like your
because
dad
japanese me and my best i don't know i
can't see it
me and my best friend just came out of
boot camp and all hyped up about like
the whole warrior [ __ ] so we're like we
need to get like something tough so we
we google translated fearless the asian
guy google translated
the asia tattoo on his [ __ ] who's none
of this is making he's korean i'm
chinese right let's pick neutral
territory japanese so we both don't know
the language
and then that's the
decision territory you're [ __ ] 18 i'm
sorry no we're just funny
just like you know japan occupied both
of those yeah first of all you should
have picked you should have picked
ireland so then you could have just
wrote in english
real neutral territory i don't fear
anyone
it's got an accident
it's got an accident i don't fear anyone
pretty good dude i like that so it's
supposed to be fear no one but google
translate of course [ __ ] it up so it's
like i uh everyone i fear or something
so the way he found out was my mom was
reading it she goes who's he afraid of
and i'm like what
i just see your mom being like staring
at his shin and being like damn this qr
code
is qr code and see what it is
no but like on paper that's like one of
the funniest stories ever because
there's always that [ __ ] running gag
about you getting a tattoo in a
different language and it doesn't it's
just water and it's usually white dudes
but it's a change
but it fits and the white dudes added it
we got it in north carolina the guy's
like hey i don't know the language so
i'm just going to trust you guys well no
we got it at least he was honest
he was honest with you guys so we used
to google man but you didn't have one
japanese friend in the military at the
time it was me and yeah you guys all
white all black you know that's it
colonel tanabe colonel watson
but they weren't cool they were cool
yeah
[Music]
you